[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález tres meses
de arduas negociaciones se llegaron a un
aparente buen puerto argentina y el
fondo monetario internacional se
pusieron de acuerdo y resolvieron
diferencias en un escenario en el que
había presión sobre el gobierno
argentino para conseguir extender los
plazos de pago de la deuda el país
suramericano presenta una compleja
situación económica desde hace ya unos
cuatro años las reservas del banco
central se han visto afectadas hay
también una alta inflación hay
devaluación entre otros aspectos que se
han visto profundizados por la crisis de
la pandemia del cob y 19 esto fue lo que
dijo el presidente de la república
argentina sobre este tema este acuerdo
no nos condiciona podremos actuar
ejerciendo nuestra soberanía y llevar
adelante
nuestras políticas de crecimiento
desarrollo injusticia social
es un acuerdo basado en la confianza del
mundo en nuestras capacidades
tenemos que crecer para poder pagar de
otro modo no era posible y debemos
honrar nuestras obligaciones al mismo
tiempo que hacemos una argentina más
justa con más desarrollo con mejor
infraestructura
ahora el reto es crecer pagar y
estabilizar la economía porque la
situación apremia según las cifras del
2021 el 45 por ciento de los argentinos
son pobres y hay otro 20% de la
población que está al borde de caer en
la pobreza el 2022 se ve en el panorama
como un año que podría ser un poco más
alentador para los argentinos qué fue lo
que negoció el gobierno cómo van a pagar
estas obligaciones es esta negociación
la que más de compañía argentina hoy en
el debate de france 24 analizamos y
trataremos de entender en palabras
simples el acuerdo alcanzado entre la
república argentina y el fondo monetario
internacional para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a diana mondino ellas
economista de la universidad del cema en
argentina ya se encuentra en la ciudad
de buenos aires también allí en la
capital argentina está gabriel
rubinstein él es director de gran
consultora el fue en su momento también
representante del ministro de economía y
producción roberto lavagna ante el banco
central esto entre los años 2002 y 2005
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en este con todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de las redes sociales no
se encuentran en facebook en instagram y
en twitter estamos como france24 regala
ya abajo yo bajo ese y arroba santi logo
que es mi cuenta personal les recuerdo
que la etiqueta es numeral el debate efe
24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas en torno a este tema supongo
que para muchos en américa latina puede
resultar interesante entender cuál es la
situación económica en argentina sobre
esta negociación bye voy a comenzar
entonces con diana hay en la ciudad de
buenos aires- dándole primero la
bienvenida al programa gracias por
acompañarnos hoy diana y quiero conocer
como punto de partida su opinión sobre
este acuerdo alcanzado entre el gobierno
argentino y el fondo monetario
internacional
gracias por la invitación y va a ser un
placer charlar con gabriel rubinstein no
digo cuántos años hace que nos conocemos
mira en realidad no es un acuerdo
todavía es este se han sentado las bases
de un entendimiento en donde hay algunos
lineamientos comunes pero todavía no
está formalmente no sólo está aprobado
por parte del directorio del fondo ni
del congreso argentino sino que entiendo
yo que todavía no están redactados los
detalles del acuerdo de todas maneras
tenemos suficiente información ya para
poder hacer una pequeña apreciación
inicial esto es un acuerdo en donde el
déficit y carl se vaya reduciendo muy
paulatinamente y donde prácticamente
todo el ajuste queda para el año 2024 25
para que no nos están escuchando eso
para decir bueno es una forma de ordena
a la economía que va a no provocar un
verdadero desajuste pero también
tengamos en cuenta
el próximo gobierno o cualquiera que sea
de cualquier signo político que sea
recién asumen el 24 así que las buenas
señales que este ajuste era necesario
para evitar con este entendimiento era
necesario para evitar un un default pero
las medidas que haya que tomar para
verdaderamente cumplir con lo que sea
que al final termine siendo el acuerdo
van a caer un poco sobre este gobierno y
otro poco sobre el próximo y asuma bien
bien bien bien a fines 2023
pensemos en todas las números que vamos
a estar hablando seguramente que
realmente impactan en los años 2000 24
gabriel su opinión sus impresiones sobre
este acuerdo por lo menos este
entendimiento como nos aclara diana
también desde la ciudad de buenos aires
que ha alcanzado el gobierno del
presidente fernández y el fondo
monetario internacional ella ya lo decía
falta la aprobación de el congreso
argentino y también de el fondo
monetario sólo vamos a analizar más
adelante en cuanto a las cargas
políticas que puede haber allí en el
interior del congreso cuál es su opinión
si el título también gracias por
limitación que sí coincidió con lo que
está comentando diana mondino a la vez
ahí hay algo bastante llamativo que es
el compromiso de una expansión de la
base monetaria de del 1% del pp y con un
déficit del dos y medio por ciento del
pbi para este año recordemos que más o
menos fue 4% del pp y con lo cual
aparentemente hay una idea de ajustar
mucho en la mansión monetaria pero eso
solamente sería compatible
si hay mucho fondo nuevo extra
que está implícito en lo tanto lo que
dice argentina como lo que es lo que
dijo el fondo monetario que va a ser
importante el apoyo de los países amigos
y demás
porque
digamos las metas propuestas de
reducción de emisión monetaria y de
acumulación de reservas requieren de un
fondeo externo que genera dudas
sobre la posibilidad de lograrlo de
nuevo fondeo externo sea del banco
mundial y del bid de la caf de rusia de
china de quien fuera pero estamos
hablando de cifras del orden de los
cinco mil millones de dólares o sea que
hay una y hay bastantes dudas en cuanto
a lo que a veces se llama la 'letra
chica' pero en cuanto al entendimiento
de la me mientras con el fondo es un muy
buen comienzo porque veníamos a una
situación justamente que podría ser muy
caótica si no se lograba esto pero
recién en el inicio de un camino que hay
que ver bien cómo se siembran todas las
piezas no y esa esa búsqueda por parte
del gobierno argentino vemos que ya hay
una agenda al presidente fernández va a
viajar a moscú ya beijing precisamente
para reunirse con los representantes de
los gobiernos de estos dos países para
buscar ahí un poco más de cooperación y
ayuda ya vamos a mirar eso lo tengo en
mi agenda para debatirlo quiero que
sigamos analizando estos puntos
iniciales y claves de este acuerdo en
gabriel en palabras claves para los que
no somos economistas que no entendemos
mucho de este tema y mucho menos del
problema de la deuda argentina que es
algo que hemos visto como por ciclos a
lo largo de las últimas décadas a que se
comprometió el gobierno argentino ahora
profundicemos entonces en eso empiezo
por gabriel
bueno el gobierno se comprometió a hacer
ciertos ajustes fiscales para bajar el
déficit fiscal y se comprometió en
principio a una fuerte reducción de la
expansión monetaria
es es condición necesaria para bajar
fuertemente la inflación que como visité
y sabes es del orden del 50 por ciento
anual y también se está comprometiendo
acumular dólares en el banco central
esas son las grandes
digamos en
compromisos que en este momento está
asumiendo el gobierno pero hay algunos
puntos que piensas que no están del todo
claros pero de todas maneras el
compromiso fundamental diría que pasa
por héctor por estos elementos no bajar
el déficit bajar más fuerte mucho más
fuerte todavía la emisión monetaria y
aumentar la cantidad de reservas del
banco central
jana en ese orden de ideas citó al
ministro martín guzmán que es el que
daba a conocer también algunos puntos
relacionados con este pacto está el
acuerdo alcanzado entre las dos partes
y es que gabriel menciona el tema de la
inflación que es tal vez uno de los que
más preocupa a los argentinos en este
momento en el día a día y el ministro
dice que se atacará con un conjunto de
políticas que apuntan a promover el
desarrollo de los sectores que tienen la
capacidad de generar divisas en nuestra
economía en qué capacidad está argentina
de empezar a diversificar esos sectores
para llegar hacia ese fin que que
plantea el ministro es fácil en este
momento dadas las condiciones en las que
está argentina y tengamos en cuenta el
escenario en el que estamos la pandemia
del 19 que no sabemos qué puede pasar en
tres meses
en este momento argentina
sorprendentemente para los que nos están
escuchando tienen limitadas las
exportaciones argentinas aplica fuertes
restricciones a todas las exportaciones
tiene un impuesto muy importante sobre
el valor externo en el peor de los casos
llega a un 35 por ciento del valor de
venta de las ganancias y además el
impuesto a las ganancias tenemos en
argentina un tipo de cambio dual que no
es fácil de explicar pero digamos un
exportador obra al dinero de hoy 100
pesos pero si alguien quisiera comprar
dólares lo tendría que comprar 210 220
sobre eso si empezó a aplicar el
impuesto que mencionaba yo recién
entonces esa situación hace que los
exportadores realmente estén muy
limitados en su capacidad de poder
crecer
agreguemos las restricciones
cuantitativas que se aplican
fundamentalmente en exportaciones
agropecuarias y la verdad que bueno
modificando esta regulación argentina
podría crecer muchísimo en pero
muchísimo muchísimo muchísimo en
exportaciones pero ideológicamente o por
algunas razones que los economistas
argentinos no logramos entender estas
restricciones ya llevan muchos años y no
se han eliminado
entonces se puede crecer en
exportaciones claramente si
el que agregar una cosita más algo muy
importante argentina no basa sus
exportaciones en tener mano de obra
barata como ha sido el caso de los
países del sudeste asiático
argentina basa sus deportaciones sobre
todo las agropecuarias o
agroindustriales en una enorme
productividad y las exportaciones
propiamente dichas industriales o
forestales o mineras también son
bastante eficientes bastante eficaces no
pero no pueden crecer o restricciones
logísticas y por estas reflexiones
cambiarias que decidan
gabriel y jana plantea un punto
importante de esta política con unos
altos contenidos ideológicos que ya ha
demostrado que tal vez no es la fórmula
que necesita argentina que tanto peso
político entra en juego en estas tomas
de decisiones y que dependiendo del
mandatario de turno se maneja la
política argentina en el sector de la
economía que permite estos baches o por
lo menos como yo lo puedo entender que
tal vez a muchas personas qué pasa es
que argentina cae en estos ciclos de
crisis económica vuelve y sale vemos
otra vez la alta inflación el peso por
el suelo frente al dólar y la situación
de la pobreza aumentando y esto lo vemos
casi que de manera cíclica porque
argentina le cuesta tanto salirse de
esos ciclos
yo diría que
no hay consensos en argentina de cómo
debería ser el modelo económico o la
forma normal de digamos de vivir la
economía es como que hay muchos
extremos en el sentido de ir a con
políticas muy estatistas
que general después en algún momento
fracasan se recurre más a políticas más
de 6 gol y ver al pero tampoco son
suficientemente profundas o no perduran
en el tiempo y entonces tenemos muchos
zigzagueos entre políticas más liberales
que apuestan a la inversión privada y
políticas más estatistas o populistas
que apuestan a la inversión pública oa
que sea el estado el que maneje o regule
demasiado al sector privado pero todo
eso crea también algún ambiente muy
negativo para la inversión privada
productiva la inversión privada es lo
que realmente genera más productividad y
más empleo
por formar y empleo productivo y
entonces eso está creciendo muy poco en
la argentina entonces como hay poca
inversión en poco crecimiento y entonces
hay como un permanente tironeo
digamos sin crecimiento también las
clases puro que se llama las pujas
distributivas o lo que quiere cada
sector también se exacerba eso es una
economía que ha estado con muchos
zigzagueos como decía también diana con
el país que dice queremos aumentar las
exportaciones
pero el día siguiente toman medidas que
restringen las exportaciones entonces
todo eso generan los empresarios que son
los verdaderos creadores de riqueza para
que la economía crezca crea mucha
zozobra entonces solamente prosperan
malos los empresarios amigos del
gobierno es una economía que cada vez es
menos productiva y cada vez se va
degradando
entonces salir de eso todavía no hemos
logrado la forma la forma donde haya
cierto grado de dinamismo les de
consensos sobre cosas que no se van a
alterar cada vez que ganen un gobierno
que gane otro
y que puede haber una cierta
certidumbre para que la inversión pueda
florecer lo
como diana salir de ese escenario de
incertidumbre de esa zozobra que plantea
gabriel en su respuesta que genere más
confianza para el mercado argentino que
sea más atractivo para invertir allí
mucho más confiable incluso para los
argentinos que no se despierten de un
día para otro sin saber si el país va a
poder pagar si el país va a poder asumir
los compromisos internacionales
que escenas se le presenta argentinas en
el escenario internacional y si el peso
un día vale al otro día no es muy
difícil romper esos ciclos de
incertidumbre de generar confianza
si estábamos en una situación en donde
la posibilidad de generar confianza creo
que ni siquiera se lo plantea lo que el
gobierno quiere es no generar más
problemas en este momento esa es una de
las razones por las cuales han llegado a
un entendimiento con el fondo monetario
a ver creo que abre lo explicaba muy
bien
nosotros tenemos cambios muy abruptos en
la economía porque es para que nos
escucha dice bueno pero qué problema hay
que haya digamos participación estatal y
el tema es que en argentina el estado es
extremadamente ineficiente
y en algunos casos digamos que los
grados de corrupción no son pequeños
entonces él cuando se quiere modificar
ese tipo de cosas hay ganadores y
perdedores dentro de la sociedad y esa
situación hace que los ganadores estén
tranquilos
hagan mejor tienen mejores servicios
funcionan bien la electricidad los
teléfonos los transportes pero aquellos
que perdieron sus privilegios
básicamente las empresas que en su
momento hayan sido de amigos del
gobierno
y bueno generan presiones para que esto
se modifique en este momento en
argentina por ejemplo tenemos tarifas de
electricidad
extremadamente bajas cuando todos
sabemos que en el mundo esto no es fácil
de mantener esto es parece un ejemplo es
una anécdota pequeña pero es una de las
situaciones por las que vamos cambiando
y lo que va ocurriendo es que la
relación que hay entre las empresas y la
gente que trabajan las familias de la
gente que trabaja se va disociando se va
eliminando porque hay una participación
de impuestos cada vez más alta esto pues
también por realmente sorprenda en otros
países porque todo el mundo tiene que
pagar sus impuestos en argentina tenemos
mucha gente que paga muchos impuestos y
algunos por su situación de pobreza o
por que evaden los impuestos pagan muy
poco entonces esto genera también
asimetrías esas asimetrías va a llevar
muchos años
haciendo converger va a llevar mucho
tiempo que haya un horizonte común pero
que se puede justamente el argumento de
las exportaciones es el más válido de
todos porque eso simplemente genera más
actividad económica sin perjudicar a
ninguno ahora sí esa parte creo que es
muy grande programa una una cosita que
quedó suelta que dijo gabriel que súper
importante y me gustaría enfatizar la el
hecho de que tengamos un déficit lo que
está indicando es que argentina necesita
endeudarse más provendrá de
multilaterales provendrá de algún otro
país que puede hacer un esfuerzo pero
realmente argentina
el gobierno adjudica sus problemas al
alto nivel de endeudamiento
cuando en realidad en estos últimos años
no estamos pagando casi nada más que
intereses no estábamos reduciendo el
qlailé endeudamiento en sí mismo y este
acuerdo nos lleva a estar más endeudados
porque el déficit implica más deuda con
alguien
entonces ahí hay una trampa discursiva
de decir si estamos saliendo de un
problema de endeudamiento endeudándonos
más es como el borracho que a la mañana
quiere tomar una botella de vino claro
difícilmente tengo un resultado positivo
eso me lleva a citar al presidente
fernández cuando dio esta alocución
desde la quinta de olivos anunciándole a
la nación este pacto y está este
entendimiento con el fondo internacional
dice que este entendimiento precisamente
prevé sostener la recuperación económica
ya iniciada verdaderamente argentina
está en un proceso de recuperación
económica en este momento diana
bueno depende como lo miras con respecto
a lo que fue el año 2020 en donde
argentina tuvo una de las cuarentenas
más estrictas del mundo más prolongadas
este claramente si ha habido una mejora
y sobre todo ha habido una mejora desde
unas elecciones que tuvimos del medio
término en agosto septiembre octubre el
gobierno inició de una muy agresiva
política social de digamos
te vas a reír pero vemos se regalaban
bicicletas calefactores etc y eso generó
muchísimo a nivel de actividad ahora eso
es persiste entre consistente perdurable
en el tiempo y la única forma de que eso
sea por deron en el tiempo es que haya
un salario real mejor y rentabilidad
para las empresas y yo no veo que eso se
ha generalizado todavía en la economía
pero de nuevo es verdad estamos mejor en
el año 2020
soy cuanto dureta no lo sé
gabriel le pregunto si argentina
necesita hacer unas reformas tan
estructurales tan de sus bases
obviamente pasan por ser reformas
impopulares
todo esto de cara a pensar en el futuro
no en la coyuntura de este momento sino
garantizarle que argentina puede estar o
puede tener un poco más de respiro en el
futuro con este tema económico no hay
nadie en argentina en los gobiernos que
están allí que estén dispuestos a
sacrificar prestigio la popularidad
a cambio de generar un cambio y sentar
bases para un cambio pensando en el
futuro como lo ve usted
yo creo que valdría la pena distinguir
por lo menos didácticamente entre los
problemas acuciantes por ejemplo la
inflación altísima para cualquiera que
está viviendo en cualquier país normal
del mundo hablar que tenemos 50 por
ciento de inflación es algo muy difícil
de entender eso se puede lograr
digamos
de una manera bajando lo que se llama el
déficit fiscal en principio está incluso
acá podríamos no pensar en subir algún
impuesto bajar x gastos etcétera para
ordenar la macroeconomía y no necesitar
que permanentemente haya una emisión
inflacionaria y eso sería un aspecto de
la coyuntura pero para crecer para bolt
para pensar que argentina puede crecer
ahora es un rebote económico como decía
diana se cayó mucho en el 2020 se
recuperó en 2021 pero no podemos saber
que la economía esté creciendo
la economía está básicamente estancada
para crecer sostenidamente el país
necesita mucha más
productividad y necesita esa apuesta a
la inversión privada y a las
regulaciones que
promuevan la inversión entonces
eso requeriría que a veces no es
cuestión de perder popularidad para los
políticos porque incluso argentina ha
tenido experiencias en los años 90 e
incluso en el 85 cuando se hizo el plan
austral
[Música]
una reforma más profunda no sólo se
logra esta vida económica sino
privatización es cambios regulatorios
etcétera donde el gobierno que lo hizo
como le fue bien fue popular o sea que a
veces es una cuestión
de hecho diría que el todos los
políticos hoy están entrando en una zona
[Música]
de un cono de sombras en el sentido que
van perdiendo popularidad porque la
economía no funciona el país no funciona
entonces no se trata de decir bueno para
hacer reformas se necesita
ser impopular el que las haga bien
también va a tener popularidad del tema
es que lógicamente
hay que tener un tipo de liderazgo y
ciertos consensos políticos para que se
vean que las reformas que se hagan no se
van a torcer
a los pocos metros de iniciada se
necesita
definir esas pautas que no no van contra
la población no son reformas que uno
dice y esto se hacen tales reformas
como por ejemplo si bueno apostemos a la
exportación no le pongamos trabas a la
exportación y eso es bueno para todos
hagamos ese tipo de cosas y no las otras
más que sean sensatas que no se vea que
sea un perjuicio para la población a lo
sumo puede ser un perjuicio por ejemplo
hay ciertas reformas laborales que
poseen perjuicios para unos
sindicalistas pero no para la población
en general u otras reformas que pueden
traer algún problema ver es cuestión de
darle esa cobertura política para que
las reformas no no se traten a poco de
andar eso es argentinas lo tiene es
dependiente lo tiene pendiente pero
bueno en la medida en que prevale los
intereses muy de corto plazo todos nos
estamos hundiendo y también los
políticos se van hundiendo en el que los
políticos las sacan fácil porque también
las popular ya los políticos va
decayendo
yo creo que se van dando condiciones
emergen liderazgos políticos que
entiendan nuestra situación que puedan
lograr consensos que no sólo van a ser
consensos entre los políticos sino que
la población va a comparar cuando ver
los resultados gabriel usted mencionaba
que es el momento para que el gobierno a
buenos diana quería comentar algo si
adelante viana partes del mundo puede
ser que las reformas propuestas sobre
todo las que se dice que en el fondo
monetario han sido negativas y han sido
impopulares han sido dañinas etcétera la
situación argentina es bastante
particular en eso está hoy por ejemplo
tenemos un serio problema con los
alquileres que existen también en otras
partes del mundo pero aquí es porque el
gobierno cobra un porcentaje fenomenal
de la entidad si el gobierno se retirará
de eso los alquileres se moverían de una
manera mucho más simple lo mismo con los
salarios el gobierno define que en
conjunto con los sindicatos cuánto debe
cobrar cada sector hay muchos de esos
temas que francamente yo creo que serían
muy populares no impopulares este no es
la misma situación
gramos de energía hay una región de
argentina que paga muy poquito y todo el
resto del país paga muchísimo entonces
igualar esas situaciones yo creo que
serían como mínimo un acto de justicia
un acto de justicia con los argentinos
sobre todo después de lo que han pasado
a lo largo de estos años gabriel
mencionaba que es el momento para que el
gobierno salga a buscar dinero en otros
en otras fuentes no solamente mantenerse
cercano al fondo monetario
internacional- con quien ha mejorado la
relación pero buscar otro tipo de
escenarios donde pueda conseguir dinero
y uno de esos comenzará en moscú en esa
gira primera gira internacional del
presidente fernández para este año va a
ir a moscú y beijing para negociar con
ambas partes comenzando por el tema ruso
y cito esto porque como no soy
economista quiero que ustedes nos
expliquen en palabras simples que puede
significar esto para para argentina y en
esa misión que tiene el presidente y es
que lo que buscan es que la posibilidad
de que el gobierno ruso les preste parte
de sus derechos especiales de giro para
fortalecer las reservas del banco
central
argentino esto como se traduce en
palabras simples qué quiere decir esto
gabriel
el fondo monetario internacional
ha puesto en marcha por lo menos en
forma conceptual y se llama en un fondo
fiduciario
donde los derechos especiales de giro de
los países
de los países que no lo necesitan puedan
estar en ese fondo y de esa manera
prestarse el todo a los países que sí lo
necesitarían como argentina todavía está
en veremos eso pero rusia es uno de los
países que podría participar de ese
mecanismo hay otros también se
puede haber otro tipo de préstamos de
rusia siempre estuvo hay una fantasía en
el gobierno por parte de la gente del
gobierno de lograr suplir al fmi con
créditos de rusia de china eso se sabe
que no es posible tanto rusia como china
especialmente
requieren que argentina no saque los
pies del plato de la comunidad
internacional y que tenga un acuerdo con
el fondo monetario pero los derechos
especiales de giro sean un fondo que el
ese fondo que se va a crear al que ya se
ha avanzado podría ser
que argentina merezca o sea digamos sea
en candidato a recibir parte de ese
fondo eso es factible de hacer así
requiere la viabilización de no solo de
rusia de china sino del propio fondo y
que justamente el programa se vaya
implementando en forma correcta y que se
cumpla no siga habría no es posible
conseguir cuando argentina hace muchos
años que están fuera del cambio
rápidamente por forma y por estar porque
se me acaba el tiempo y quiero hablar
del tema de china quiero preguntarle a
diana sobre sobre este tema allí también
en la visita que va a hacer el
presidente fernández a beijing va a
intentar obtener unos 3.000 millones de
dólares por parte del gobierno chino y
tratar de incluir a argentina en esa
llamada ruta de la seda que es este
proyecto geopolítico impulsado por
beijing para acceder a diferentes
mercados a cambio de infraestructura
préstamos etcétera que tanto de este
ingreso a esta ruta de la seda para
argentina sea estratégico o necesidad
cualquier cosa que se haga para mejorar
la infraestructura argentina y la
conectividad con el resto del mundo es
positiva nosotros no tenemos tuvimos un
infraestructura muy moderna hace casi
100 años se ha ido deteriorando se
mejora un poquito pero digamos hoy no
estamos en las mejores condiciones así
que cualquier inversión que se haga en
ese sentido es positiva pero no debemos
confundir que eso no es dinero que entra
a la economía para que el gobierno pague
una cosa que se reciban inversiones para
logística para infraestructura para
generar condiciones mejores para que la
sociedad pueda desempeñar para que la
economía funcione y otra cosa muy
diferente es que hubiera un préstamo
porque además cualquiera que dice 13
argentinas no le puede pagar a fondo
monetario que ir y ver qué acreedor más
barato que existe si además argentina
tiene déficit por lo que necesita
endeudarse más porque voy a hacer yo el
que le pague mientras argentina no pueda
pagar a los acreedores anteriores
difícilmente le van a pagar algo nuevo
muy distinto es que se hagan inversiones
y eso eventualmente va a tener una
contraprestación eso me parecería
realmente muy positivo pero
endeudamiento libre producto yo la
verdad no lo veo no lo veo no lo veo por
qué el digamos insisto si no les pagas
al acreedor anterior era barato con que
le vas a pagar a un nuevo acreedor que
va a ser más caro
claro importante esa aclaración gabriel
quiere conocer su opinión sobre este
acercamiento con china me quedan tres
minutos de programa para explicar este
último punto sobre qué tanto es
necesidad tratar de entrar en este juego
geopolítico de la ruta de la seda o
simplemente pues es estratégico para
argentina estar ahí como una gran
economía de suramérica porque así sea un
país que esté con complejos problemas
económicos sigue siendo una economía
destacada en la región
para mucho tiempo porque hay temas
geopolíticos y demás y argentina siempre
ha querido tener un su propio juego
político con las grandes potencias y
tratar de tener una especie de tercera
posición o algo por el estilo pero
tenemos que diferenciar como sea diana
lo que sería la inversión directa de
empresas chinas para ser un
gasoducto para hacer cualquier inversión
en infraestructura de lo que sea por
ejemplo ahora que se está gestionando el
uso de los swaps chinas acordados para
convertir una parte en dólares para
aportar esas reservas son cosas hay
cosas que son más financieras y hay
cosas que son más de inversión
productiva las dos pueden ser útiles en
determinados circunstancias obviamente
en la inversión productiva puede ser muy
útil y siempre hay cuestiones también a
veces de seguridad y tiene geopolíticas
que hay que atender porque hace a los
conflictos del chira con eeuu de rusia
completos sonido en fin ese es un vaivén
político que no me quiero meter mucho en
eso porque ese no emite en mente y
además que es muy largo y complejo claro
que a un minuto para cerrar el programa
quiero conocer sus conclusiones
rápidamente gabriel continuó con usted
entonces de guadiana para el cierre
conclusiones que sigue para argentina
sobre todo después de este acuerdo de
esa gira del presidente fernández y lo
que venir ahora que se está reactivando
la economía después de el confinamiento
y el cierre a nivel mundial
sí yo creo que el acuerdo es positivo no
se aleja de escenarios muy negativos nos
pone por lo menos en un escenario más
regular será un poco mediocre pero por
lo menos nos aleja del abismo de
escenarios muy complicados después se
verá
la letra chica de todo el acuerdo y la
convicción especialmente del propio
gobierno que tiene muchas
contradicciones internas
especialmente el kirchnerismo si
realmente
avalan
y avanzar con el fondo no es el grado de
cumplimiento de lo que se logre va a ser
un punto muy importante a monitorear en
los próximos meses eso está en
negociaciones en el congreso argentino
diana a su opinión para el cierre
y coincido plenamente con gabriel y nos
estamos alejando de un gran problema lo
que me gustaría pensar es que no nos
estamos metiendo en otro problema
permitiendo que esto este ejemplo que
poníamos que no sé si van a ocurrir o no
de inversiones rusas o chinas
cualquiera de estas que sean espero
ruego que sean en condiciones de
libertad de mercado que cualquiera que
quisiera las inversiones reciban las
mismas condiciones y que esté abierto
para todos quiero creer que no va a
haber condiciones especiales que no va a
haber contratos ocultos quiero creer que
no va a haber cláusulas opción de
imposible cumplimiento para que digamos
dentro de 35 ó 25 años digamos pero no
podemos modificar esto porque hasta que
el contrato claro roque más que así sea
ya ana gabriel muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros en el debate
de france 24 haber puesto en palabras
simples este tema tan complicado que es
el tema de la deuda argentina a ver aquí
pudimos entender y por lo menos disipar
algunas dudas les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros sigan dejando sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales sigan con france24
[Música]